[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace desde Puerto
Príncipe Haití en el programa de hoy
daremos un vistazo a la actualidad de
este país propenso a desastres naturales
y políticos y que además sufre de
inseguridad alimentaria violencia y
crisis sanitaria
[Música]
la situación política no está Clara en
Haití desde el magnicidio en 2021 el
país no tiene jefe de gobierno el Primer
Ministro Ariel longi se mantiene como la
máxima autoridad luego de que fuera
reconocido a través de un tuit y un
comunicado por las Naciones Unidas y la
comunidad internacional el parlamento
cesó por completo su funcionamiento con
este fin el grupo anima encarecidamente
al Primer Ministro designado Ariel en
proseguir la misión que se le ha
encomendado para formar dicho gobierno a
principios de enero expiraron los
mandatos de los únicos diez senadores
restantes dejando sin cargos electos a
un país de más de 11 millones de
habitantes sin legisladores en su cámara
o senado
la Constitución hay que decir que la
Constitución de 1987 no enmendada
preveía al presidente de la corte de
casación o el juez más antiguo para
reemplazar la vacante presidencial que
podría ser interrumpida en el transcurso
de un mandato
el Primer Ministro anunció el 6 de
febrero de este año la instalación del
llamado alto consejo de transición Ash
ct un ente que se creó con la intención
de llamar a unas próximas elecciones
el nuevo consejo también apoya la
petición de only de que se desplieguen
tropas extranjeras para ayudar a sofocar
la violencia en Haití solicitud que hizo
en octubre del 2022 y que aún no ha sido
entendida por el consejo de seguridad de
la ONU un tema que polariza a la
población del país mientras continúa la
inestabilidad política más de doscientas
pandillas están controlando el país y el
60% de ellas se encuentran en la capital
los secuestros son la principal fuente
de ingresos de estos grupos delictivos
que han dominado el país desde más de
una década pero que han ganado
territorio los últimos 10 años la ONU
advirtió que la seguridad en Haití debe
mejorar antes de que tengan lugar las
elecciones en las calles príncipe los
haitianos dicen que es más del 80% de la
capital con presencia de pandillas
grupos armados poderosos han aprovechado
el caos político y el descontento de la
población con el actual gobierno para
consolidar aún más su poder sin un
control de la violencia muchos haitianos
han sido obligados a huir de sus hogares
las noticias sobre violaciones
secuestros asesinatos y emboscadas a la
policía se han convertido en el día a
día de la capital haitiana según la red
Nacional de defensa de Derechos Humanos
en Haití 78 policías han sido asesinados
desde que llegó el Primer Ministro al
poder la policía denuncia constantemente
la falta de equipamiento un comisario de
la policía haitiana le afirmó a France
24 que para poder hacerle frente a las
pandillas necesitan cascos carros
blindados y armamento y no cuentan con
ello Muchos oficiales temen por sus
vidas
a pesar de que se reporta la disminución
de Casos de la epidemia del cólera que
surgió en octubre de 2022 los traumas
causados por armas de fuego y armas
blancas se han disparado en un sistema
de salud completamente colapsado
el sistema de salud en Haití ha estado
en crisis por años y se agravó con el
colapso de la infraestructura a causa de
los terremotos del 2010 y del 2021 un
brote de cólera también puso en Jaque al
país en octubre de 2022 Y aunque ya se
ha controlado actualmente hay un
promedio de 25.000 casos registrados y
más de 500 muertos según datos de
médicos Sin fronteras por ahora la
organización médica insiste que el
problema principal que los mantiene
ocupados y que afecta sus operaciones es
la inseguridad a diario reciben Víctimas
de la violencia se calcula que entre 60
por ciento y 70% de los pacientes que
llegan a sus salas de emergencia son por
impactos de bala
un buen número de nuestros pacientes son
Víctimas de violencia sea sin arma arma
blanca o por impacto de bala
en promedio recibimos a diario una
decena de víctimas por impactos de bala
en nuestros diferentes hospitales
entre tanto la economía quien azota a
los haitianos para diciembre de 2022
Haití había superado el 47% de inflación
sumiendo aún más en la pobreza una
población que viene sufriendo desde hace
décadas de inseguridad alimentaria según
el último análisis del programa mundial
de alimentos de las Naciones Unidas Unas
cuatro coma siete millones de personas
enfrentan actualmente inseguridad
alimentaria de las cuales uno coma ocho
millones está en fase de emergencia y
19.000 están en nivel catastrófico la
sexta básica de alimentos está fuera del
alcance de muchos haitianos distintos
factores entre los que se cuentan la
pandemia el aumento de la violencia la
inestabilidad política el cambio
climático y los desastres naturales han
influido para que la inflación siga en
aumento el Ministerio del Comercio en
Haití asegura que
84.7% de la sexta básica haitiana Son
productos importados lo que incrementa
el precio del producto por el pago de de
los importadores en la aduana crisis
económica social y política una
constante que no detiene a la migración
haitiana tras la nueva medida de acogida
decretada por Joe biden los haitianos
han encontrado otra salida para
abandonar el país muchos no se sienten a
salvo en un país que carece de gobierno
leyes y derechos fundamentales hasta
aquí enlace desde Puerto Príncipe siga
con más información por France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]